[Musique]
il est 8h 16 sur europe 1 pierre de
vilno l'interview politique david quand
vous recevez le patron des républicains
laurent poquet bonjour laurent wauquiez
bonjour vous devez d'une certaine
manière satisfait ce matin emmanuel
macron vous a écouté depuis des semaines
depuis des mois vous demander une baisse
d'impôts significative pour les classes
moyennes en particulier en diminuant
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est presque a
annoncé emmanuel macron votre voeu et il
pleinement exaucé je vous répondrai sur
sur les mesures sur lesquelles on peut
avoir des accords même si pour l'instant
il ya beaucoup de flou et avant qu'on
rentre si on me le permettait dans le
commentaire des mesures mais j'aimerais
bien su se comprennent un minimum ans de
recul qu'est-ce qui quand même est très
préoccupant dans l'intervention d'hier
je vois pas le cap je vois pas où le
président veut emmener les français et
ce que je vois c'est beaucoup de zigzags
beaucoup d'inconstance
beaucoup de changements si on regarde
quand même parce que c'est assez
impressionnant il comprit à quelques
mois d'intervalle loi de 1905 il ya
quelques mois on nous dit on y touche on
la change
hier ont la chance plus les retraites
pendant la campagne le président dit je
préserve le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
pendant deux ans il a fait exactement
l'inversé hélas en corrige on y
reviendra pas et nous aborderons tous
ces sujets immigration le président
commence par dire n'y a pas de crise
migratoire
il ya deux ans puis hier il fait un long
dégagement sur le sujet pour finir juste
en en tirant comme seule conclusion il y
aura un débat au parlement ce n'est pas
la seule il parle aussi de réformer
schengen mais nous aborderons tous et
l'armée mais je voudrais juste pour kona
les hissant à léser le dernier les
entreprises
c'était pourtant une des constances du
programme des manuels macro
on essaye de favoriser les entreprises
et la création d'emplois hier qu'est ce
qu'on apprend banon finalement on va
revenir sur les crédits d'impôt et donc
ce qui me marque
je ne vois pas le projet je vois trop de
changements je ne vois pas au fond là où
il veut nous emmener
et pour un pays et c'est par là que je
voudrais finir un président qui a pas de
boussole c'est le risque de finir avec
un quinquennat pour rien on est déjà à
mi mandat
quasiment et si on regarde avec un peu
de recul le sentiment qu'on a c'est
qu'en fait aucun chantier n'a été
sérieusement ouvert et traités sur les
deux ans qui viennent de s'écouler
hier qu'est ce qu'on a eu des
corrections à la marge d'erreur l'autre
qui avaient été commises
mais pat catalan lkp c'est quand même le
plus important nous avons entendu votre
vision générale de la conférence de
presse d'hier entre on entre on sait
nous les biens dans l'évent des sujets
parlons du fond des sujets c'est ce qui
intéresse nos concitoyens les impôts
laurent wauquiez il baisse on imagine
qu'une grande partie de nos concitoyens
qui payent l'impôt sur le revenu sont
satisfaits ce matin se disant je vais un
peu souffler oui mais ce matin il ya
aucun des français qui a écouté qui peut
savoir ce qui va se passer
vous n'êtes pas le co réalisé cette
hausse est au gouvernement d'agir
désormais votre ancien ami et gérald
darmanin et est donc moi j'ai quand même
une question simple c'est ça va
bénéficier à tout le monde ou non vous
savez que c'est mon obsession
mon obsession c'est les classes moyennes
quand on dit classes moyennes attention
parce que parfois quand on écoute ce
gouvernement quand vous êtes devant
dessous de 1800 euros vous êtes dedans
quand vous êtes au dessus vous n'êtes
plus dans ça je serais pas d'accord ac
ce qui les classe moyennes pour vous
deux classes moyennes c'est quoi quand
vous gagnez 3000 euros chacun dans un
couple vous êtes dans la partie aérienne
quand vous êtes dans une grande ville
souvent pouvoir d'achat est lourd se
loger c'est lourd et donc leur nom sera
très vigilant on a une proposition très
simple sur la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu il faut faire moins 10% pour tout
le monde ça c'est simple c'est glacé 5
milliards donc que l'impôt sur le revenu
en 2017 c'était 73 milliards on est
parent on n'est pas 10 % cette avance
est en dessous et surtout qu'elle est
quelle sera notre point de vigilance pas
de seuil
stop stop ce système ou si vous êtes à
1700 euros ça va si vous êtes à 1900 ça
va plus si vous êtes à 1700 vous avez vu
une vraie baisse si vous êtes au dessus
vous n'êtes pas dedans
tout le système fiscal français
fonctionne autour de 100 là vous
anticipez que ça ne baissera pas pour
tout le monde c'est votre lecture de
zinc pas ce qui ne lasse a précisé hier
c'est pour ça que vous savez je suis
jamais dans une opposition cinqueterre
on essaye toujours de proposer ce que je
vous dis ce matin on sera très vigilants
nous ce qu'on demande c'est baisses
d'impôts sur leurs hauts pour tout le
monde alors on laisse pas de côté une
partie des classes moyennes alors
baisser les impôts bon c'est acté 5
milliards de baisses et c'est le souhait
du président comment on finance ça c'est
un sujet le financement de cette baisse
le président de la république parle de
la nécessité de travailler davantage il
a il a clarifié les choses là dessus pas
de jour férié en moins
on maintient l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 62 ans en fait son levier
c'est le nombre de durée de la durée de
cotisation pour les retraites
qu'est ce que vous pensez de saint
laurent wauquiez monsieur doukan sautez
pas là-dessus tout de suite vous aux
jambes et corps n'est point mais la
première question est la dépense
publique ont fait courir la dépense
publique on y verra rires dedans et ça
c'est sans doute le deuxième point
extrêmement fragile et tous ceux qui
nous écoutent doivent le comprendre
le président de la république hier n'a
rien annoncé de sérieux et de solides
sur la baisse de la dépense publique
il a même renoncé à la seule mesure qui
était à peu près concrètes dans ses
engagements qui étaient la baisse du
nombre de fonctionnaires 120000 jean
rappelle c'était la promesse 120000
actionnaires de moins d'ici 2022 le
président et fière a admis qu'il
pourrait y renoncer si ce n'était pas
tenable et donc qu'est ce que ça veut
dire tous ceux qui nous écoutent le
comprennent très bien il faut pas
chercher à mentir aux français si jamais
il n'y a pas de baisse sérieuse de la
dépense publique de ce que coûte le
fonctionnement administratif de l'état
mais il est évident que les ailes les
baisses d'impôts ne pourront jamais être
durable à moins que son phrase de la
dette
à moins qu'on fasse de la dette ce qui
est la pire des choses ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le danger là aussi on
sera très vigilants c'est que les
cadeaux d'aujourd'hui financé à coups de
déficits budgétaires
ça peut faire les impôts de demain et ça
c'est ma préoccupation parce que je
considère que ça n'est pas sérieux c'est
pas un travail sérieux ce qu'ils font le
président de la république laurent
wauquiez dit qu'il va supprimer des
organismes publics qui dit il sont
inutiles ne précise pas lesquelles pour
vous c'est insuffisant
la dépense publique doit être de réduire
de manière beaucoup plus drastiques à
vos yeux vous le savez gère une région
la région vers le ronald kent des
grandes régions françaises
en trois ans j'ai baissé de 15 % les
dépenses de fonctionnement de ma région
j'ai été une des régions qui a fait le
plus d'économies sur les frais de
fonctionnement
du coup ça m'a permis quoi ça m'a permis
ensuite de baisser les impôts des taxes
mais après hélas qui va pas du tout dans
ce qu'est cette approche c'est que comme
y'a pas un travail sérieux sur la
dépense publique
il n'y aura pas de baisse durable des
impôts et ça c'est vraiment la bataille
que j'essaye de faire il faut qu'on
arrive en france à se repositionner et
je suis convaincu que les français
attendent un discours de vérité de la
part de leurs aînés comme vous dites
d'abaisser à dépenses publiques par
exemple vous préconisez quoi combien de
fonctionnaires en moins c'est ce qu'on
fait le un sur deux comme nicolas
sarkozy l'avait fait ça faisait 30 mille
fonctionnaires chacun le un sur deux a
démontré une certaine efficacité en la
matière vous vous si vous étiez aux
manettes vous supprimerions combien de
patates et puis surtout leur look et
lesquels je lesquels je vous savez cette
question là on n'a pas prise à la légère
on a fait un plan de 1 milliard d'euros
dans lequel on a listé par exemple 400
agents sous comité qui pourraient être
enlevés dans lequel on a proposé d'avoir
une simplification de notre système
social avec une seule aide sociale
insolent minima sociaux plafonné à 75 %
dans lequel on a proposé d'augmenter le
temps de travail dans la fonction
publique en compensant avec des primes
au mérite mais rien que ce calcul si on
augmentait le temps de travail ça
permettrait de générer l'équivalent de
400 mille postes et donc ça c'est ces
mesures-là sur lesquels nous on est prêt
à s'engager et vous pouvez pas avoir
hier un président de la république qui
annonce des cadeaux pourquoi parce qu'on
est avant les élections et donc la
grande crainte qu'on a c'est que bas
avant les élections dénonce les cadeaux
mais il n'y a pas les mesures de
financement qui sont en face
je rappelle que les 10 milliards d'euros
qui avait déjà été annoncé en décembre
nistre avait fini par reconnaître que
même pas 15 % était financé alors ça
c'est pas du travel 11 ans au temps de
travail parce que je veux qu'on parle
aussi de nos aînés les retraités ils ont
été au coeur aussi de la conférence de
presse oui mais avant cela le temps de
travail laurent wauquiez
si là encore si vous aviez aujourd'hui
le pouvoir
est ce que vous auriez vous plus
simplement repousser l'âge légal on
abandonne les 62 ans quelle est votre
vision avoue là dessus d'abord là encore
il ya un premier sujet qu'on ne traite
pas le temps de travail tout simplement
les 35 heures voulait dire a pris bien
sûr il vient d'augmenter les heures sup
l'ena désocialisés de l'est défiscalisés
dans ça n'aurait pas de sens
d'abandonner 35 heures d'abord un c'est
pas vrai ils veulent faire il va le
faire il annoncé mais l'annoncé le 10
décembre à bon il ya eu tellement
d'annoncer ses prochains budgets
prochain budget ont même indépendamment
de ça on n'a pas fait la défiscalisation
des heures sup mais laisse aux mêmes de
côté sajoo c'est laurent wauquiez disant
non c'est pas vrai si justement je vais
défiance ya lisation hilali
défiscalisation monsieur deux camps
soyons prêts soient les idées soyons
précis les heures supplémentaires
continueront à payer de la cvs
deuxièmement les employeurs eux n'ont
pas la déduction des charges sur toute
une partie des employeurs ça veut dire
que la réalité c'est qu'on fera pas
vraiment les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées qu'on avait avant lancé il
faut il faut qu'on soit vous vous dites
c'est les 35 heures quoi moi ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut qu'on remonte le
temps de travail voilà donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on ait
un vrai débat sur combien travail dans
notre pays
combien encore combien selon vous je
considère qu'il faut qu'on revienne à 39
heures et que ça se traduise par des
augmentations de salaire en bref un très
bref le plein emploi en 2025 c'est
l'objectif fixé par emmanuel macron est
ce que vous y croyez juste rapidement
quitté il ya personne qui nous écoutent
qui croient à 2025 comme par hasard
trois ans après la fin du week end du
quinquennat comme ça on est sûr que
personne peut relever les objectifs ça
c'est pas la politique que j'aime ça je
voudrais que nous parlions est
maintenant de nos aînés nos
grands-parents nous nos parents nos
grands parents pour ceux qui ont la
chance de les avoir encore parmi eux
peut-être est-ce la catégorie qui a été
le plus mis à contribution depuis le
début du quinquennat sur sa emmanuel
macron a bougé hier il annonce la
réindexation des retraites des pensions
pardon en dessous de 2000 euros dès le
mois de janvier
dès le mois de janvier et pour tout le
monde à partir de 2021 et puis il ya
cette annonce d'une retraite minimum
pour quelqu'un qui aurait toutes ses
cotisations mail
qu'est ce que vous dites de cela est ce
que est ce que vous auriez fait plus
pour nous pour nos aînés vous savez dans
cette période moi ça a été mon obsession
la situation des retraités de façon
quasi constante dans grand débat on
apporter ses propositions sur la
réévaluation des retraites il faut quand
même bien comprendre ce qui s'est passé
la réalité vous l'avez dit c'est que les
retraites ne seront pas revalorisés de
l'inflation cette année à bennwihr loire
attendre 2020 nord en janvier pour ceux
qui gagnent moins de zéro et 2021 pour
tous les autres exactement
et plus la hausse de l'acf et que toute
une partie des retraités vont continuer
à payer ça veut dire qu'on revient en
corse et le même seuil 1 c 2 1000 euros
1 au dessus de 2000 on continue de payer
voilà passé récent que que moi je
dénonce ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que le président de la république en
deux ans aura pris 6 à 8 milliards
d'euros sur le dos des retraités et qui
ne leur ont pas cet argent il compense
en 2020 et 2021
il annule ce qu'il a décidé ce qui est
quand même pas très glorieux quand même
cc changement de cap que je vous ai
vocal ya que les imbéciles qui ne
changent pas d'avis pourrait-on dire
enfin ça fait peut-être cher le coût de
formation d'un président la république
mais surtout la réalité c'est qu'il a
pris 6 à 8 milliard d'euros sur le dos
des retraités et que ça ne le rend pas
et un deuxième exemple qui est important
et sur lequel joue on s'arrête de
seconde pour les automobilistes tout cas
c'est un autre sujet mais il est
important allez-y il n'y a pas eu un mot
sur la question hier en 2018 des
nouvelles taxes ont été appliquées elles
sont toujours en vigueur aujourd'hui
quand vous allez à la pompe et vous
faites votre plein d'essence les prix
ont à nouveau exploser pas un mot
là-dessus
dans la conférence d'hier du président
de la république pourtant jamais le prix
de l'essence n'a été aussi haut
n'oublions pas que ça a été à l'origine
de la crise mme et donc ça ça montre que
on n'a toujours pas compris ce qu'est la
situation des français qui vont
travailler en prenant leur voiture les
retraités les automobilistes c'est sans
doute les deux catégories qui reste
largement en marge des mesures qui ont
été annoncées aujourd'hui 8 milliards
d'euros pris sur le dos des retraités
qui ne sont pas rendus la question de
l'explosion du prix de l'essence qui n'a
pas été traité hier parlons un instant
du président de la république lui-même
pourquoi parce que dans cette crise des
gilet jaune il a été mis en cause
personnellement sur les ronds-points
dans les manifestations emmanuel macron
nous dit
le sentiment que j'ai donné c'est d'être
dur d'être injuste
il regrette finalement de l'avoir
d'avoir donné ce sentiment il regrette
ces phrases qui ont pu être blessante
est ce que vous croyez
laurent wauquiez emmanuel macron sincère
lorsqu'il ya culpa je suis pas là pour
faire un cours de psychologie du
président de la république et ça
n'intéresse pas les français nous disent
ont été blessées il dit qu'il regrette
sans doute que ça les intéresse quand
même un petit peu
il nous dit qu'il a changé - ma crainte
c'est qu'il change tout le temps il a
des paroles qui parfois peuvent être
touchante dans ce qu'on a écouté hier
mais le problème chez lui c'est pas les
paroles c'est l'action qui est derrière
quand par exemple il nous dit bon bah
sur l'islamisme et il faut qu'on fasse
un il faut qu'on fasse du travail on n'a
pas expulsé sérieusement les imams
l'étranger près sûr de m on a pris les
djihadistes sur le sol français ils ont
fini par reconnaître qu'ils avaient
accepté 210 à 10 de retour sur la
question des mosquées salafistes même
pas une dizaine a été fermé donc hier
quand il nous dit on
attention il faut qu'on lâche rien sur
l'islam politique où sont les arguments
ne le croyez pas vous le courriel à
l'aide ses sais pas ce que je veux dire
parce que je cherche pas être dans une
position de défiance systématique mais
ça m'intéresse sur ce sujet là faut-il
avoir qu'il y ait de la concorde juste
face au terrorisme force face au
djihadisme plus que de la concorde
monsieur de caen faut surtout de la
détermination
quand on voit ce qui s'est installée sur
l'antisémitisme quand on voit ce qui
s'est installée dans notre pays sur la
haine sur les attentats c'est cette
détermination pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que ce qui me gêne c'est qu'hier
je n'ai pas senti cette constance un
président ça peut pas être une pirouette
quand on pense trop à l'arrivée il faut
qu'on conclut laurent wauquiez en un mot
il a dit je me fiche de la prochaine
élection présidentielle fossiles a
invoqué
croyez sincèrement à politique quand ils
vous disent merci laurent wauquiez vous
êtes le président des républicains
merci d'avoir été notre invité